(p(piano)
- - C'est la maison de 16 colocs
ququi ont entre 22 à 61 ans.
(p(piano)
L L'an dernier, la majorité
d'd'entre eux habitaient encore
chchez leur parents.
IlIls et elles ont leur propre
chchambre et recoivent
l'l'assistance continue
nénécessaire.
- - On les respecte tous, tous,
totoutes leurs particularités
sosont respectées. Tout ce qu'is
aiaiment, tout ce qu'ils n'aimet
papas.
- - C'est devenu chez eux.
SASARAH HUXLEY, responsable de
rerecherche et developpement,
- - On continue d'avoir des déf,
pupuis on va toujours d'avoir
dedes défis, c'est sûr, c'est
unune population particulière.
MaMais les progrès sont énormes.
On v voit des progrès dans
lala communication, on voit
dedes progrès dans
leles interactions entre eux
auaussi, surtout, en fait,
dadans les liens qu'ils vont
dédévelopper. Donc, au début,
ilils communiquaient beaucoup
avavec juste les intervenants,
mamais de plus en plus,
ilils interagissent entre eux,
ilils se font des compliments,
ilils remarquent ce que les auts
fofont, ils se disent : bonjour.
- - C'est une maison épurée,
adadaptée aux particularités
dedes autistes, mais c'est aussi
lala vision des fondateurs
VéVéronique Cloutier et
LoLouis Morrissette qui se sont
lalaissés guider par le réseau
dede la santé bien avant
l'l'inauguration.
- - Comment allez-vous,
auaujourd'hui? Est-ce que ça va?
- - Il y a une éducatrice
popour quatre résidents.
LeLe programme d'activités
vivise à les stimuler
etet à développer le potentiel
dede chacun.
- - Tout doux sur la joue.e.
(b(bisou)
EsEst-ce qu'elle peut en faire
unun autre?
- - Oui.
- - Sur l'autre joue.
(b(bisou)
(r(rires)
- - Je suis content!
- - T'as plein de bisous!
- - Un an plus tard, ce sont
enencore les mêmes résidents.
KAKATTY TAILLON, dg FoFondation
VéVéro et Louis
- - Pour la plupart, je vous
didirais qu'après six mois,
l'l'integration était quand meme
fafaite, mais on les connaissait
papas par coeur. Puis même après
unun an, il y en a qui
nonous surprennent encore.
L'L'équipe a vraiment tout fait
popour q que ces résidents-là
s's'adaptent, soient compris,
paparce qu'il y en a plusieurs i
sosont non verbales. Si jamais l
y y a des crises ou des
dédésorganisations, on sait quoi
fafaire maintenant.
- - De partout au Québec,
KaKatty Taillon recoit
dedes messages de parents.
L Le modèle est encore à l'essi
etet quatre études universitairs
vovont permettre de l'évaluer.
LeLe Centre de santé et de
seservices sociaux de la
MoMontérégie Ouest, qui finance
leles services offerts à la Main
VéVéro et Louis, et qui gère aui
leles demandes d'hébergement,
y y voit la possibilité
dede faire mieux, en regroupant
leles clientèles qui
sese ressemblent.
LALAURENCE PÉRUSSE-TARDIF,
CoCoordonnatrice des programmes
- - Je pense que pourquoi
onon commence de plus en plus
àà voir des profils de solutions
rérésidentielles personnalisées,
c'c'est justement parce qu'on
s's'adaptete plus aux besoins
dede l'usager dans les dernières
anannées que peut-être, avant,
onon était plus dans
unune institutionnalisation.
- - Elle a les oreilles droites,
drdroites, puis collées. Ça,
çaça veut dire qu'elle
esest très, très bien.
- - Répondre aussi aux besoins
plplus sensoriels comme la magie
ququ'apporte parfois
lala zoothérapie.
LYLYSE CERVELLIN, zoothérapeute
- - Il y a aucun participant
icici qui fait semblant d'être
heheureux. C'est naturel, c'est
dedes réactions spontanées;
dedes vraies reactions. Tu sais,
ilils sont pas capables de
fafaire semblant. Puis quand
ilils ne veulent pas, ils le
didisent, puis c'est super corrt
paparce que... pour certains,
onon travaille ça aussi, de dir:
nonon.
- - Je suis content de ça!
- - Dès l'automne, on souhaite
ououvrir certaines activités
dede jour à des adultes autistes
dudu secteur.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie
Radio-Canada, à Varenne